[Music]
you do a song about Chris Farley yeah
yeah our old pal Chris Farley and we all
love a few guys of course we're very
close what's that all about it honestly
like on the show we we've been running
around doing this stand-up show together
it's been the best time and I gotta say
that's like the highlight every time
because we sing a song about Chris and
all of us kind of just think about our
grade and the audience goes bananas boom
because you just think about but anyways
yeah those guys were the tightest that
David and Chris was so tight and like
but I was tight with Chris on like those
guys were like real best friends I I was
another kind of best friend he had heat
when he'd get pissed at David barley
he'd always come over to me like he had
a crazy temper Farley so he would just
be stewing mad about nothing about him
but just like whatever like if a girl
talk to me be like well I get so angry
that David was talking to a girl or
something he'd be like I'm gonna kill
him I'm gonna punch him and I'd say II
don't
Wow don't hit him and he'd be like no I
got I got it I'm gonna crush her
and I would say cuz it doesn't make any
sense if you not come out you know
there's a jerk and if you lose my god
you're known as just a giant puss like
you're right you're right you're right I
can see him oh yeah all right oh ya know
and then I would go at him I think Chris
is gonna beat me up you were real were
you really afraid that Chris would beat
you up one time he left me the most
horrifying voicemail which they should
have kept I've I he's gonna smash
through the base of it and then I didn't
come to work and then I got back to him
and I saw me good did you get my joke
I know I didn't sound like you're
kidding you guys don't tell horn
you